good morning Hank it's Tuesday so a
while back I said in a video in the
United States women make 77 cents for
every dollar that men make in the
workforce and a lot of people pushback
in comments you know the wage gap is a
lie that myth has been debunked you're
an idiot with no apostrophe etc anyway
now after a lot of reading I am going to
attempt to share what I have learned
about the gender pay gap hopefully
without inciting a flame war in the
comments this whole question is
fiendishly complex and people far
smarter than I am have spent their whole
careers devoted to it but I want to
begin with a broad observation there is
a gender pay gap among full-time workers
around the world but the size of the
gender pay gap varies dramatically by
country like in New Zealand women
working full-time make on average 90
cents for every dollar that a man
working full time makes whereas in South
Korea that number is just 62 cents when
it comes to calculating the pay gap in
the United States a lot depends on what
exactly you're calculating like by
hourly wage the pay gap is about 16
percent my weekly take-home pay it's
between 18 and 19 percent by annual
earnings it's around 21 percent the
fuzziness here speaks to the complexity
of what we're about to get into but
basically men on average work more hours
than women on average actually no they
don't but men work more paid hours right
but so this 16 to 21 percent number just
looks at all full-time workers it
doesn't account for differences in
education or skills or experience or
occupation when you factor all that
stuff in the pay gap shrinks to
somewhere between four and eight percent
depending on who's doing the math this
is the so-called unexplained pickapp
that is there is no economic explanation
for it and most nonpartisan analyses
agree that this part of the pay gap is
directly due to gender discrimination by
the way you can find links to lots of
sources in the doobly-doo but yeah
that's four to eight percent number
might sound low but even on the
extremely conservative end it would mean
that women lose over 241 million dollars
of pay every year to direct
discrimination
I should add here that there is also a
wide racial pay gap in the United States
and as discussed in this vlogbrothers
video there is overwhelming evidence
that much of that gap is due to direct
discrimination because race and gender
affect people long before they enter the
workforce it's difficult to disentangle
causes here but we do know that women of
color are doubly disadvantaged when it
comes to pay
Arlis of skill level experience or
education right so a portion of the
gender wage gap is attributable to
discrimination in the United States but
most of it is ostensibly about choice
choice of college majors or flexibility
when it comes to hours or occupation and
this is what people generally mean when
they talk about debunking the gender
wage gap women on average work fewer
hours and tend to work in less lucrative
professions from school teaching to
caregiving whereas men are more likely
to work in higher paying fields like
engineering or anesthesiology and some
of the pay gap can be found here like in
one study of more than 120 professions
more women than men worked in nine of
the ten lowest paying jobs but of course
that isn't only about choice it's also
about the expectations of the social
order like why are there more female
nurse anesthetists
but more male anesthesiologists and then
there's the fact that even within almost
all of these professions the pay gap
persists from computer programmers to
teachers to lawyers some of this is the
after mentioned unexplained pay gap but
some of it is because men on average
work more paid hours than women which
brings us to the question of unpaid work
the average adult American woman spends
167 minutes per day on housework or care
for household members for the average
adult American male it's a hundred one
minutes per day and that work even
though it's unpaid is of course very
real now none of this is to criticize
the many women and many men who work
fewer hours or don't work in the labor
force at all to focus on child care or
housework it's only to say that women
doing a disproportionate amount of the
unpaid labor in the United States
inevitably distorts the paid labor
market we see this especially clearly in
studies of what happens to workers after
they have kids with each child a family
has women see their average income
relative to men go down it goes down
about 7.5% after the first child they're
gonna tell the studies exploring this
but I just want to highlight one in 2007
a Stanford professor sent out fictitious
resumes to various firms and found that
female applicants with children were
less likely to be offered positions and
when offered jobs were offered lower
starting salaries men meanwhile actually
seemed to fare better after they have
children in both employment
opportunities and wages this may also be
part of the reason the pay gap gets
worse over time it's near ten percent
from young adulthood until about the age
of 35 when it suddenly jumps up like one
study looking at
the school graduates found that right
out of school there was a relatively
small gap but then eight years later it
was much much larger and interestingly
even in careers dominated by women men
disproportionately advanced to
supervisory roles like most librarians
are women but male librarians are
disproportionately likely to become
library directors and there are still
large pay gaps within careers that
employ mostly women from nursing to
librarianship in fact unless you really
cherry-pick the data a real and
consistent gender pay gap exists across
almost all fields at all education
levels at all ages and at the current
rate of change this wage gap won't close
in the United States until 2050 eight in
short Hank there is a gender pay gap but
it is not as simple as women making 77
or 79 cents for every dollar men make
instead it's an extremely complicated
web of inter woven factors some of the
pay gap is attributable to positive
empowered choices that individual women
make to work less or to work in fields
they find more fulfilling much of it is
due to direct discrimination against
women especially mothers and much of it
is also due to the way our social order
constructs gender and our expectations
of women and that is something we can
change together by for instance
embracing the idea that there's no
reason for the social order to saddle
women with most of the world's unpaid
work and we can also examine the real
personal and systemic biases that are
distorting the way that we look at women
in the workplace and outside of it so
the gender pay gap is complicated and
it's integrated with many other
socio-economic phenomena but make no
mistake it is real Hank I'll see you on
Friday